Ця трійця має великі плани на 2018 рік.
Насамперед щодо проблем міграції,
реформи Єврозони
і, звісно ж, щодо брексіту.
Поки що виглядає, ніби в ЄС ще достатньо часу, аби вирішити ці проблеми.
Утім, канцлерка ФРН Анґела Меркель може трохи змішати карти.
Адже допоки в Німеччині не сформовано уряду,
її руки зв'язані.
Політик, який хоче додати проекту "Європа" свіжих ідей, -
французький президент Еммануель Макрон.
Багато промов - багато візій ще глибшої європейської інтеграції.
Одна з них - створити європейський валютний фонд,
аби вберегти країни ЄС від банкрутства.
Як, приміром, Грецію у 2010-му.
Ще одна ідея - власний бюджет Єврозони.
Для інвестицій або щоб згладжувати економічні потрясіння.
Утім, далеко не всі в ЄС такі ідеї підтримують.
Серед скептиків - і Німеччина.
Тріщина у питанні, що доцільніше - більше інвестувати чи більше економити?
Також тріщина між Заходом та Сходом.
Насамперед щодо проблеми міграції.
Брюссель хоче врегулювати питання притулку для біженців найпізніше до червня.
Однак східноєвропейські лідери, зокрема президент Угорщини Віктор Орбан,
і чути не хочуть про квотний розподіл біженців між країнами ЄС.
На цю проблему накладається ще й згортання демократичних свобод у Польщі.
На тлі цього тріщина між Сходом та Заходом у 2018 може стати ще глибшою
Утім, є тема, яка об’єднує всі країни ЄС - це Brexit.
Досі жодних розбіжностей щодо цього у 27 членів спільноти не виникало.
Утім, 2018 року на порядку денному стоїть
майбутнє торгівельних відносин між ЄС та Великобританією.
Тобто, також таких секторів економіки як німецький автопром.
Слід чекати великих конфліктів інтересів.
Час спливає, проблеми залишаються:
Біженці, реформа Єврозони, Brexit.
Щодо всіх цих тем ЄС мусить порозумітися у 2018 році,
аби ці проблеми не переросли у ще більші.